and it will be thrown by luis heal
23 years old from the dominican republic
six to 185
in two starts he's thrown 11 scoreless
innings allowed only six hits struck out
14 while walking three
breaking balls sky to right
giancarlo stanton toward the line for
the catch i circled him and bogarts
who's at the plate now because they can
get on top of high fastballs
spanx this one to center field but
gardner is right there
now dever's in the cleanup spot 29
homers and a league leading 89 rbis
and wade may have a chance here as he
drifts into the outfield and then gallow
comes in and calls him off and that's
that for the red sox in the top of the
first and ivaldi he is among other
things a strike thrower nearly 70
percent what he does better than any
pitcher in the league is defend the home
run the lowest home run rate that's
always important when you face the
yankees especially at yankee stadium dj
lemay hughes starts it
breaking ball grounded toward the hole
and through
and lemay he was on to start the yankee
first here's aaron judge played right
field in the first game d.h in the
second typically he likes to cut her
here 3-2
he gets judge gardner running
strikeout and a steal so he swipes the
bag with two out and it brings up gallow
this ball is as high as it is far
into left center field and who's going
to take it it's going to be verdugo for
the catch that finishes the yankees
in the bottom of the first jd martinez
will start it in the second for boston
this ball is hit sharply through the
middle
and a base hit for jd martinez
finally get to see a fastball for jd
martinez he was happy to see that kevin
plowaki is catching the second game
strike three for lucky down looking got
him on a slider and it brings up jaron
duran the center fielder
swinging a missed strike three you're
not gonna get that pitch this guy's got
a good fastball i mean you notice with
polwecki went sliders here young hitter
up there bigger swing that fastball is
the go-to pitch just keep throwing it up
there now travis shaw
there it is martinez singled schwarber
walked
and then heels struck out polecki duran
and shaw in order changing speeds on his
delivery
here it is there it is yeah and he gets
stanton looking look at the difference
in the delivery odor
odor strikes out two quick strikeouts in
the book of the second inning for ivaldi
here's voight
a drive to deep right this ball is gone
it got out in a hurry his sixth of a
difficult year for him this is only the
39th game in which he has played
well he's never met a first pitch
fastball he didn't like nathan avaldi
only the 10th home run allowed in 24
starts this year
luke boyd doesn't care if the pitch is
in the zone tonight he sees fastball
he's going to pull the trigger
[ __ ] has really done the job for cora
high pop
wider first and foul ground here's
voight to tuck it away for the first out
and there's the second out as verdugo
takes third
and now devers hits one to center and
gardner is there to take it so verdugo
is stranded we go to the bottom of the
third and most of his two strike hits
are
two right field
look at that
no sooner do you say it then he obliges
didn't hit it through it hit it over it
but same basic idea
he's such a good hitter so now aaron
judge oh for three with a walk in the
first game and a strikeout on the first
inning of this one here's a drive to
deep center field
duran goes back
on the track he makes the catch
higashiyoka tags and moves to third and
le mayhew holds first gallow now at the
plate
and gallows strikes out so the yankees
leave a couple and after three they
still lead it one to nothing you go to
the bottom of the fourth inning it's
stanton
drill deep to left center field there it
goes
see ya
a long home run for stanton two nothing
yanks wow see you later swing his 19th
of the year stanton homer's to love
center a stantonian home run
a high pop-up and there have been plenty
of those tonight
and it's shawn foul ground
he's the first with nobody out
guys who can run
just have a different look
and shaw isn't running he's walking back
to the dugout and the red sox will have
runners at first and third
verdugo sends one out to left that
should produce a run with duran tagging
at third
and he is not going anywhere what's up
with that gallow has a great arm but
durant has terrific speed i mean alex is
saying it's a good decision i think
that's giving gallow too much credit
on four pitches bogart's walks and the
bases are loaded peralta the left-hander
in the pen
and it looks like heel will last only
four and two-thirds bases loaded
durant at third hernandez at second bow
guards at first
and the two two pitch
is a bouncing ball to second le mayhew
underhands to wade and the red sox leave
the bases loaded and luis heal has still
not yielded a run in the major leagues
wanting for all the stays of the game
he retired rafi devers to end a bases
loaded threat in the fifth gets martinez
to fly out to start the sixth and now
faces schwarber but it applies here as
schwarber sends one through the middle
for a one-out hit
plucky now
struck out fouled out la mahu to his
left skids to a stop throws to wave
beautiful play for the force out at
second
le mayhew won three gold gloves playing
what is his natural position second base
as a member of the colorado rockies and
he showed you why there the red sox have
runners at the corners with two outs
peralta who scrambles to pick it up and
pants to first
to get him
that stings a little but in the other
dugout it also stings that in the last
two frames
they've stranded five
chad green has had his successes and
failures this year including against the
guy he'll start it against [ __ ]
hernandez
voight
chasing after it make it la mayhew
that's one of the changes and le mayhew
makes a nice play
to retire hernandez
two-nothing yankees top of the seventh
one out nobody on
and down goes verdugo
[Applause]
a slow roller velasquez on the run he
got him
comes into the game
gets to make the play that seals it not
a routine play either all those
defensive moves paid off